The Texas Chainsaw Massacre is one of
the most important horror films of all
time not only did it inspire a
half-dozen sequels and reboot films it
was also a completely new addition to
the horror genre that opened the
floodgates of gore Leatherface is still
one of the most unsettling villains in
movie history and there's a rich history
behind the first movie in the series
that even the most die-hard of the
Leatherface fans might be surprised to
learn keep watching to learn the untold
truth of the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
under the boardwalk when director tobe
Hooper and writer Kim Hankel decided to
team up again after their previous
collaboration on the low-budget indie
movie eggshells they knew they wanted to
do something in the horror milieu but
what at first the pair considered a more
sinister version of the already dark
Hansel and Gretel fable but then they
look to another type of fairy tale
narrative trolls well not those trolls
more like these trolls if they'd gone
with their original thinking the movie
would have been called headcheese and
followed a group of trolls living under
a bridge it might have been about as
successful as their experimental
eggshells if they hadn't come up with a
more mainstream concept
luckily they stumbled upon a killer new
idea
Ed Gein and then some any Texas Chainsaw
fan worth his or her salt knows that
Leatherface was in large part inspired
by real-life killer
Ed Gein but he wasn't the only skin
loving psychopath to lend some creepy
realism to the story Cooper told Texas
Monthly that the idea for Leatherface
was actually derived from a story his
doctor once told about a med school
prank where he cut off a corpses face
when he was in pre-med school he skinned
a cadavers face cure you know dried it
out
for a masked Halloween party that's cool
that's not all
Koopa also looked to at accent in serial
murderer named Elmer Wayne Henley Hooper
explained he kind of puffed out his
chest and said I did these crimes and
I'm gonna stand up and take it like a
man
well that struck me as interesting that
he had this conventional morality at
that point he wanted it known that now
that he was caught he would do the right
thing so this kind of moral
schizophrenia is something I tried to
build into the characters chain
spiration as for the movies mood river
in Hankel had to look no further than
the news to get a read on the cultural
unrest that existed at the end of the
Vietnam War
meanwhile the idea to implement a
chainsaw as the weapon of choice came
from a particularly terrible holiday
shopping trip to a local Montgomery
Ward's I found myself in front of a
chainsaw display in the hardware
department and that's where the idea
came from well if I pick this damn thing
up and started it apart like I said like
the Red Sea surprise poopa kept his
Leatherface actor gonna Henson
quarantined from the rest of the cost
until it was time for him to elicit some
real scares so when he finally popped on
to the scene he gave his co-stars quite
a fright it was just one of the many
methods Hooper would use to evoke honest
tension from his stars he admitted in an
interview to using a similar tactic when
it came to the wheelchair-bound
character Franklin saying we wouldn't
let Franklin have lunch with the other
actors and we wouldn't let him bathe
beef it's not what's for dinner one of
the central themes of the first Texas
Chain Saw movie was the way that the
victims were butchered in such similar
ways to animals directed tobe Hooper who
himself had become a vegetarian due to
the perceived cruelty of the meat
industry actually used the
slaughterhouse he passed by on regular
drives as a set for the film because it
played such a
heavy part in the philosophical
undertones of the pic he explained in an
interview I had an experience in a
restaurant one time where there was a
huge trolley with beef being carved up
and I just transposed different images
onto it like what if there was a nice
little cow there with a bowtie a knife
carving up humans it always disturbs me
it became part of the psychology of the
film he later admitted that he thought
that the heart of the film was about
meat even though the characters
cannibalism isn't directly confirmed in
the original others agreed in fact the
People for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals better known as Peter has given
the film the nod of being among the most
Pro veg flicks of all time while fellow
genre author llamo del Toro went meat
free for a while as a result of the
movie
from that moment on till four years
later I didn't need any meat Genta
seemed pretty good del Toro didn't take
the time to see sausage party huh
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know about your
favorite Texas Chainsaw moment